the joggin experience I think people are
concerned that this is kind of setting a
precedent and that this is going to be
something that we have to do in the
future is there a way to prevent
something like this a full shutdown of
the of the country to happen in the
future
well the way is you know we you know
we've got this incredible scientific
infrastructure in America right the best
research universities and institutes in
the world and and I work at two of them
the Baylor College of Medicine in Texas
Children's Hospital and and now I'm
doing a few things with Texas A&M
University and Baylor University as well
and and and Rice and so the the the
answer is this is why we have a and then
I ain't sure the budget of thirty six
billion dollars annually we need to have
a pipeline of technologies getting ready
for this epidemic we we should have you
know if we had you know all the funding
we needed for a corona virus vaccine
program we would have had several
coronavirus vaccines and clinical trials
and potentially we could have combined
them in a way to be ready to go now
so having figuring out a way to support
organizations that don't are that are
looking at vaccines and other
countermeasures not in terms of promise
they can sell that are going to help the
help the health security of the country
I think is really important so one of
the books that I wrote is called Blue
Marble health and it finds this unusual
and we spoke a little bit about this
last time the unusual number of
illnesses from emerging infections like
this one and poverty related neglected
disease is actually in the g20 countries
the g20 economies the 20 wealthiest
economies especially the poor living in
those actually account for most of these
diseases and the problem is the g20
economies are not stepping up to support
these technologies we still rely too
much on the US and the UK and the
European Union
we've got to do better with China and
Brazil in some of these countries to
help fund these global health
technologies because that's all we have
otherwise we go back again back to the
14th century in terms of social
isolation
[Applause]